حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه زابولوجيا
الجنوبيه البلاد ان الثلاثه مدنيين قتلوا
واصيب خمسه في قصفا روسيا صاروخي على
المدينه
واضافت الاداره العسكريه ان القصف ادى الى
تدمير اجزاء من مبنى سكني وتضرر المباني
المجاوره
وفي ضخمه قالت انا مليار نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
محاولاتها التقدم في اتجاه المدينه
والسيطره عليها بشكل كامل رغم تكبدها
خسائر كبيره واضافات المليار في بيان عبر
منصه تيليجرام ان الوضع مازال تحت السيطره
لكنه يتطلب تدابير دفاعيه مناسبه من
الجانب الاوكراني حسب تعبيرها واشارت
مليار الى انه هجوم القوه الروسيه مستمر
من اربعه اتجاهات وهي لمن وباخموتا